en otros vídeos hemos hablado acerca de
como las moléculas pequeñas o los iones
eran capaces de atravesar la membrana de
una célula ya sea de manera activa o
pasiva o facilitada de lo que quiero
hablar en este vídeo es de cómo cosas
más grandes
entran a la célula aquí nos enfocaremos
en el transporte de objetos de elevada
masa molecular también conocida como
transporte en masa déjame notarlo voy a
hablar del transporte
corte en masa
y como primer ejemplo quiero que te
imagines una célula como esta membrana
morada que tengo aquí como puedes ver en
el dibujo la membrana está rodeando a
una gran cosa verde que puede ser una
bacteria u otra cosa déjame hacerlo más
claro
aquí tengo la parte interna de la célula
adentro adentro y acá tengo la parte
externa así que le voy a poner afuera
como ves la membrana celular comienza a
envolver poco a poco este objeto de gran
masa verde que pensemos que es una
bacteria lo empieza a envolver poco a
poco hasta que de repente la envuelve
completamente y la parte de la membrana
que envolvía a la bacteria se desprende
del resto de la membrana y ahora la
bacteria date cuenta que ya está adentro
de la célula y además que está envuelta
por la membrana justo como por aquí a
este proceso donde se envuelven cosas se
le conoce con el nombre de pagos
entonces
sin dosis y el prefijo fago viene del
griego y significa comer ya que este
proceso es literalmente acerca del comer
de la célula y en muchos casos esta cosa
que ahora está adentro de la célula que
de hecho puedes verlo como la comunidad
de la célula aquí en este compartimiento
donde se encuentra la bacteria que será
transportada a lo mejor a un lisosoma
para ser procesada y así digerir a la
bacteria a este grande compartimiento
derivado de la membrana celular lo
llamamos vacuola digestiva esto de aquí
es una vacuola vacuola digestiva
y
ahora vayamos a este escenario de aquí
abajo este escenario es similar pero
diferente aquí vemos esta parte de la
membrana celular de color magenta
podemos ver la bicapa fosfolípido por
eso dibujé dos líneas para representar
la membrana esta es la pica para
fosfolípido y puedes observar en este
dibujo que en lugar de que la membrana
rodea una partícula grande en este caso
va a rodear algún líquido como te das
cuenta rodea una parte del líquido y
después empieza a rodearlo a rodearlo
hasta que se desprende y ahora esto se
va al interior de la célula ojo estoy
dibujando todo esto en dos dimensiones
pero realmente sucede en tres
dimensiones esto no es sólo un círculo
esto de aquí debería de ser una esfera
ya esta esfera que ahora se despegó de
esta membrana celular se le conoce con
el nombre de vesícula esta de aquí es
una de circular
que es un término general que se usa
para estos compartimientos derivados de
la membrana celular que ahora están
dentro de las células a este proceso
donde las células están esencialmente
bebiendo un líquido y bueno junto con lo
que hay en él se le conoce con el nombre
de pinos y ptosis
no sin dosis
y el prefijo pino también viene del
griego y significa vender y siempre me
ha fascinado las raíces de las palabras
10 que a decir verdad no soy un
lingüista experto pero está increíble
que varias lenguas como el indio o el
urdu los cuales conozco bastante bien la
palabra pino significa beber entonces a
lo mejor está relacionada con la palabra
polling que está en estas dos lenguas
estoy casi seguro que tienen una raíz
lingüística común y siempre me parece
fascinante ver todas estas conexiones
lingüísticas
pero bueno regresemos pinos y ptosis
donde la célula está viviendo por así
decirlo y pagos y ptosis donde la célula
está comiendo por así decirlo y justo
estos dos procesos que tenemos aquí
estos dos procesos especiales donde se
rodea de esta manera a estas partículas
a estos dos procesos se les conoce con
el nombre de endocitosis déjame
escribirlo endocitosis
en dos dosis es decir no te confundas la
fagocitosis es un tipo de endocitosis y
la pinos y ptosis también es un tipo de
endocitosis ahora bien seguramente te
puedes hacer la siguiente pregunta ok ya
vi cómo sucede esto inclusive lo puedo
ver en el microscopio pero cómo es que
sucede como la membrana envuelve
partículas y después la suelta y como
dije en muchos vídeos varias personas
creen que esto se entiende muy bien sin
embargo estos procesos no se entienden
completamente hay algunas ideas que
dicen que el citoesqueleto está
involucrado y entonces de alguna manera
empuja por aquí a la membrana creando
así este espacio para que bueno se
desprenda y después se mueva en alguna
dirección oa lo mejor también actúa
ayudando a la membrana para que sirva
como envoltura de justo esto que tenemos
aquí en fin todas estas son áreas que se
están estudiando y preguntas como cómo
es que ocurre la endocitosis
la pregunta de cómo sabe la célula que
consumir y que no o la pregunta de y
cómo es que la membrana logra hacer esto
de la manera adecuada son preguntas que
todavía no tienen respuesta